we are here in the beautiful studios of
la talk radio with mr. mark Rosen Bush
filmmaker 2 point 0 sin noir and we just
had the pleasure of speaking with mark
on today's radio show and as a gesture
of thank you we would like to present
you with this t-shirt we've teamed up
with snorgtees and we would like to
present you with this wonderful t-shirt
here we are whoops other way coupon so
here's your t-shirt assistant to the
regional manager excellent this this
fits very well with my with my what I'm
teaching that you should be your own
boss and take control of your own
destiny and not be anybody's assistant
so I'm happy to have this and in fact i
will i will probably i'll probably be
more likely to give this to my business
partner because it'll drive him crazy to
have to wear this and i would be the
regional manager so thank you thank you